[Music]
what is this the third time that we've
done this yeah
third time third time right yeah only
three last time was a couple years ago
in a little motel on the off the freeway
in in Marshall Texas right huge huge
town in Marshall Texas it's been a it's
been quite a road even blazing my friend
yeah I don't know it's uh it doesn't
feel like I'm blazing it it just feels
like it's happening and I'm along for
the ride and I'm okay with it
and because uh I don't feel like I'm in
control most at a time it's a surrender
bad you know I mean and you're being
guided I think yeah yeah I think so too
well it's been a while since you've been
on the show the hardcores the longtime
listeners know your story well but the
show's grown quite a bit yeah
so I think it would be helpful to just
recap your story a little bit I don't
want to dwell on it because we've gone
into it so much in other episodes but
for the people that are new let's like
take a look back for a minute yeah well
look back is uh you know a kid on the
Bayou in south Louisiana living the
dream of hunting and fishing almost
every weekend with all the people you
love and fry and everything and drinking
beer and telling jokes and making
friends and connections but also getting
really heavy and mixed with that I had
an identity of being a football player
so I really felt like being a big guy
and just those things mixed together and
that lifestyle and that culture and that
identity by the time I was 32 or so I
found myself about 420 pounds right how
old were you done about 30 to 32 yeah
and and talk to me a little bit more
about the culture the culture fashion is
good some of the best people you ever
meet in your life and you and you know
what we do
what we do is it's almost like this this
a fancy phrase it's not my phrases how
its phrase but it's a toxic imitation of
respecting like our ancestry because
what they really were doing with the
foods that we really sort of overeat
today those things were founded in times
of scarcity is like a survival to you
know how to eat every single piece of
the pig in a Boucherie or whatever or
get crawfish out of the small and that
culture what we do today is we sort of
over indulge in those things that were
really just helping us get through times
of scarcity and the bulk of those old
Cajun meals were a lot of like
vegetables you know backyard garden
vegetables and things like that but we
kinda have gotten off of the rails and
are just sort of watering in this toxic
imitation of honoring our ancestry by
killing ourselves with these survival
techniques they use to make it through
times of real difficult scarcity you
know well I would suggest it's even more
complicated than that because it's so
intertwined with I mean those traditions
are so intertwined with family and love
it's very emotional yeah and so they
symbolize more than just fill in the
belly right this is it this is about you
know honoring you know honoring these
traditions that have been going on for
generations and generations where you
come from to break ranks with that is
more than just hey I want to slim down
it's a it's a rejection of a lifestyle
it's a slap in the face to my mom it's a
slap in the face to your uncle so-and-so
who fries the best fish or fries the
best gratz hanz what do you mean you
know
uh-huh and like it literally pissed off
at you yeah so that's difficult you know
so growing up playing football hunting
fishing drinking drinking the football
went away they really balloon
oh you what were you when you were at
your fighting way playing ball playin
ball I was like 292 330 in that range
you still had a hundred to go yeah
and tell me a little bit about what it's
like to carry that kind of weight around
it's it's a job man it's a full-time job
I didn't I don't you know you don't
think about it at a time that that will
you know boil frog kind of a thing you
don't realize it because it happens so
slowly mm-hmm but it's just tiring your
feet are always hurting your ankles are
always hurting you always just trying to
you're on your feet but you are
immediately need to get to another place
to sit down that's a lot of work it's
it's you know the funny things like like
in the first conversation we had about
being on an airplane and needing an
extension or then moving me to the front
of the plane that stuff is embarrassing
yeah but but not only that just the
physical pain and then the physical
things that think about just the way I
think about this because I'm dealing
with my back over the past year so the
way my spine would have to contort when
I have this big giant belly and I'm
bending over to tie my shoes it put on
line my own you know socks and without
it mashes against my lumbar spine I
spend so much time thinking about what
I've done to my body um but it
regardless of what I've done to it today
feels a hell of a lot different than it
felt back then being mashed down to the
earth with right a extra 200 pounds on
my body I can't imagine I'll throw on a
25 weight vest right now to go do some
training hikes and I can't imagine
having 200 weight vest I'm not going for
yeah I can tell you yeah
what about emotionally it's like night
and day
in my life honestly you know I got
bitter
I was angry a lot sort of mad at myself
but really projecting that anger mm-hmm
in situations on other people like God
and the wonderful things on us look at
all like what is wrong you know you know
now I still have a lot of those
pressures a lot of those stress sores in
my life that stuff going on but I feel
lighter not only physically but in my
inside of my mind inside my heart and I
handle those things in a completely
different way I cry a lot more than yeah
you know like you cry all the time
but I'm okay with it like my bambam
cried a lie he was a tough bastard so
but it's okay to wear your heart on
sleeve you know and that has helped like
it it's it's cleansing mm-hmm and that
has helped me I think
release a lot of physical weight as well
really sort of dumping in mindset and
and listening to my first virtual
podcast is where I started to turn the
rudder that in that direction you know
that you you were where I was learning
these things right yeah you first
I mean I've told the story a million
times but for people that are new you
first came across my radar when you
tweet it you tagged me in a tweet that
had a before and an after picture I just
I just couldn't believe it was the same
guy this enormous you know 400 plus was
like another picture of a guy who looked
like Bradley Cooper I'm like this camp
this is like early days of the podcast
I'm still doing Skype interviews and and
that was all I knew and you I think you
had written like a manifesto on your
blog yeah and I was I was touched by
that
and that's all I knew about you and I
was like I'm gonna I'm gonna take a
flier and get this guy on the show and
then you came oh we did a Skype call and
I just could not believe your story and
that and that testimony you you know you
trusting me to kind of you know share
your experience touched a lot of people
and I said to you in the wake of that
you've got to find a way to like share
your story I don't know what you know I
don't know what your career situation is
what's going on down there but I'm
telling you man people need to hear your
story it's super powerful so do whatever
you need to do to get yourself out there
and and and not only have you like taken
that and run with it
like it's just amazing now to look back
and and see I mean you had made so much
progress up to that point but after that
you've gone on and I mean at that point
I think you'd run a half marathon you
hadn't even get a marathon yeah you know
yeah I don't know how many marathons a
lot of marathons doesn't know you've run
ultra marathons you won an ultra
marathon and now you're sitting across
from me because you were attending the
plant Rishon you know the plant Rishon
conference the big plant based nutrition
conference that's held every year you're
you're getting up on stages you're
sharing your story mm-hmm you're writing
a book right now it's like it's so
inspiring to see that that see the
impact that you're making now and I
think it's just starting and well it's
just about getting you know honestly I
learned it from you I learned it from
like like you know that a bunch of the
podcasts I'm drawing a blank on the guys
name right now I hate it it's what it
was I've texted you before it's one of
my very few French champion and remember
that Oh Jeff Spencer yes yes and so that
like things like that was like nuggets
where it's like oh it's not about this
race specifically it's a bigger thing
it's about something greater it's about
being part acting in a way that you sort
of organically collect the team around
you that helps you get something great
you know
and I was seeing you do that you you
were doing it you were accumulating and
in an organic way and that's all I've
done is like hey this is something I can
do this is something that feels good
I like talking to people I like running
is fun we have we're building and
community I'm helping keep helping
friends that I know avoid heart disease
lose some weight this is awesome it's
right in the vein of my happiness and
you just start chasing that and it grows
and serendipity happens along the way
and like these amazing things but you go
to a place like play nutrition cut the
plant tration project and it's a it's a
thousand doctors who most of them are
already plant-based but some of them
maybe are there because their plant
curious and you're looking and they just
heard them some science Ted's got him
but to be staying in there as like a C
student from Jack Bay Louisiana worried
about and being able to talk to a doctor
about what we're doing you know and have
that person come up to me and want to
take my picture because they know me
from the ritual podcast is a hell of an
icebreaker I know what I mean that is a
huge like validation to me that I don't
know if you know that you gave me that
just it feels good to be able to use
that in a way that it's helping other
people you know well you are helping a
lot of people and I think when I look
back on on how you kind of went from
from that place to where you're at now
you know I'm sure people come up to you
and say like how did you do that how are
you in this place where you get to you
know give talks and the like you just
showed up and said yes to the next thing
it's not like hey I'm gonna I'm gonna
wipe like training for a marathon where
you're like okay here's the date and
here the work outside to put in it's
more like surfing you've gotta like ride
this wave and when you're president
you're paying attention and and you've
done enough interior work to be able to
trust your instincts you know what the
right next move is you do that and you
be open to the possibility that that
will guide you or lead you to the next
thing
and their tiny little steps that seem
like they mean nothing in the moment or
yeah I'm gonna go down to the community
center and talk to whatever but you
don't know what's gonna come of that you
don't know who's there who's gonna talk
to somebody else that'll lead to some
other thing and I think the and this has
been my experience as well like people
like how are you like how did you go to
Nantucket Pro how are you doing it's
like I just showed up man I said yes a
lot you know this it was I opened my
heart and and then I really feel like
I've been guided it was not a it was not
a plan then I laid forth in front of me
like this is where I want to be it was
about saying yes and and learning how to
surf that wave and that means saying no
to other stuff too like what's what's
moving you forward what's not but you've
done that in such a beautiful way but I
think of all the things that you've done
or that you're involved with it's really
cool to you know look look the weight
loss story is like the weigh-in because
that's so dramatic and you know
obviously that's what everyone wants to
know about with you and then you look at
the the races that you've done ultra
marathons like all this crazy stuff is
super inspiring but to me the most
inspiring thing that you do is how you
give back to to your community and the
love that you have for your neighborhood
essentially and I think that is what is
most needed and lacking right now not
just in the health and fitness nutrition
plant-based movement but in society at
large like we need that was a big theme
of the Nantucket project this past
weekend Lincoln neighborhoods community
how can we learn to better and more
effectively communicate with our fellows
and that's something that you're
succeeding at in the way that you're
serving people calm so can you talk a
little bit about that I just want to
have a conversation with with people at
home that's my audience that's who I
talked to that's that's where that's
where I'm facing everything I ever
posted on social media
um because they're closest to my heart
they're closest to me geographically
I've been me people don't even know
their name maybe I've seen them five
times in my life but I've seen that
person five times in my life at Walmart
because we're both from Toledo like and
so that matters that's that's where you
speak the language that's where you can
have the most impact and these are the
people that not only need it the most
but our you know the people that that
are sort of forgotten yes like
absolutely I could go do some talk in
Brentwood it's like they're already hip
to it or whatever I'm in my silo you
know but my trailer park I'm not about
to go to plan stop they're not going
they're not going to the veg fest you
know so you're able to communicate with
these people in a way that almost nobody
else can mm-hmm and so what is that like
how do you do that and what is that
about I just use the same language that
I would talk about deer hunting or
fishing or anything else with but we
just have that same report over this
stuff I've learned about food and this
stuff I've learned about running and hey
you should try it a little bit and
luckily our local hospital has built
this giant Wellness Center in Thibodaux
so it's kind of like the in thing to do
to be active so I have conversations in
the locker room would not become the in
thing to do because they spent 70
million dollars on a gigantic Wellness
Center that is it's the lot edad now in
Thibodaux man that's where most of it
just sits around you know shooting the
[ __ ] and now I'm talking at the bench um
you know not really doing a whole lot
not breaking a whole lot of sweat but
they're there and it's and it's alive in
the in the you know in the community
like there's at least a movement towards
less moving some not he still serve
crazy stuff and cafe and all but I get
to talk about that to them through my
social media you know without
necessarily directly railing against
people in the trial I don't I try not to
make myself you know on what
but it's difficult sometimes and exactly
crafting like how to talk to the people
on the body about a plant-based diet and
about disease reversal without and then
listening to me is I'm just the Trailer
Park guy from Jack baby why should I
listen to you my cardiologist says you
don't know what you're talking about
I'm gonna go with him alright so but
being able to come and let the people
that are back home see me do what I'm
doing right now see me go to see me on
social media go to other places and go
oh yeah he might just be from shagged me
but people all over want to hear from
him so maybe even though he sounds like
us he walks like us he talks like us
maybe he doesn't know what he's talking
about just goes from chadway maybe you
know it doesn't necessarily mean he's a
total dumbass
what if someone doesn't know you from
social media
like what's the opener like you go into
a group of people maybe it's a community
gathering you got people that are obese
or you know have diabetes type 2
diabetes they're you know spent their
entire life eating poor boys and you
know doing what you do and fishing and
hunting coming from a completely
different perspective from you know the
kind of kale chomping you know vegan
that sure the west side of Los Angeles
sure I just told you know if you think
about our grandparents if you think it's
a lot of garden vegetables does a big
part of of being a Cajun is having a
garden and having those garden
vegetables like on a regular like a lot
of it you know I let's steer towards
potatoes I'm not asking you to stop
being a hunter I'm not asking you to
stop fishing I'm asking you to pay
attention for just a second about
something that I learned about these
heart attacks that we go to funerals for
all the time and there's there's a know
whether or not you want to do anything
about it once you learn this that's on
you don't you do you but for right now
let me show you this and here's how we
can get it done and you can still have
your cake and eat it too you can still
go fishing if you want you still go
hunting if you want but let's do
let's get rid of dairy let's get rid so
they to understand where my friends are
at the moment and be willing to talk to
them where from that place without
trying to shatter their whole world
right and have a conversation about
their health and about what that means
to their family pod that means a lot to
them you know so that's where we have
the conversation that's where I have the
conversations with the guys about how to
get traction or how to even get desired
1/2 traction in this behavior change
yeah it's one thing if you're you're
staring down the barrel of like a crazy
health crisis like your doctor dealing
you you're gonna have a heart attack any
day now or you're gonna get your foot
amputated or something like that like
that will inspire and motivate somebody
to make a change but but what if you're
just you know you're walking around with
50 extra pounds on you and you don't
look any different than anyone else and
you feel okay well Nakata you get
through to somebody like that who's like
yeah I hear what you're saying like what
you've done is inspiring like I should
probably better do something different
but like how do I even begin to do that
well that's the thing is that's where
for me that's the health come there the
health part of it is because it doesn't
matter I know they're people that are
completely slim that have six-pack abs
they drop dead of heart attacks because
you there's ways to physically
manipulate the amount of adipose tissue
you have on you your body that does not
necessarily translate to healthy
endothelial and then this is that is
like from just a dude that went to check
the elementary I just read a couple of
books and listen to dr. Esselstyn on a
documentary you don't have to like
become scientists to understand that and
see that so you can be only fifty pounds
overweight you can be proud of me for
having lost 230 pounds you can feel like
you don't really need to do anything cuz
you not 230 pounds overweight however if
you're eating the standard American diet
you are gonna be on the road to like at
least being
the bevy of cardiac medications that
that's that basically you go in for the
first thing and you get on all of those
things you know the first cardiac thing
you could give you it on all of those
meds you're at least gonna have that if
not you know what is it 25 percent of
the time that the first sign of
cardiovascular disease is a sudden death
right that's that's a big number to me I
don't want to play that game especially
since I know that my families especially
all the men in my family seem to die of
heart attacks so I'm gonna do it
different and I'm I'm onto some
information they were not on to it seems
irresponsible of me to like it forgive
me and bam bam if I was following him in
a boat and he ran across a sandbar and
he added the sandbar and then I followed
him right into the sandbar I hit the
same damn sandbar but I'd be in trouble
you know pay attention and that's all
that that's what I would tell that
person it ain't about your belly I'm
gonna god I don't care if you lose the
50 pounds or not you do you but this is
about something bigger this is about why
we lead the nation and heart disease
this is about why we lead the nation and
obesity and diabetes and all these
things one of the things that that that
is pretty remarkable about what you've
done is that you you did it in this
community really without any support at
least not any support in terms of boots
on the ground sure no Whole Foods nearby
no immersion program down the street you
know something inside of you just just
clicked and you made it happen
essentially on your own and I think
that's probably a big part of what
compels you to try to create you know
programs in your area so that the next
person doesn't have to do it alone but
one of the biggest things you hear about
the plant-based lifestyle is I you know
I can't afford that food you know like
I'm not you know I'm on a budget here
that's great and for you but you know
it's not gonna work it's not gonna work
for me
so as somebody who lives you know we're
in an area where most people do their
shopping at Walmart and like what do you
say to those folks you doing it wrong
you're doing it wrong
if it's expensive you're buying the
wrong [ __ ] at the store sorry you I'm
not that's what you may need to adjust
what your mind stay in the produce
department and you need your buy rice
and your buy beans and your buy potatoes
you need to get the you know that's
that's the bulk of our food it is
expensive to buy processed stuff it is
expensive to buy premade meals it is
expensive I agree with you on that
but that's not where we should be eating
we should be eating these things that we
can buy 10 pounds of it at a time and
we'll be fine it's traditionally Popper
food right it is exactly what it is and
so and I love the quote that I heard
from dr. Esselstyn and in one of his
talks one time is there's a certain
dignity in simplicity and when you stay
in the produce department and you walk
out with you know a ten pound bag of
potatoes some bell peppers a few you
know a few onions a couple avocados and
a bag of kale and some may be a thing
full of almonds or some walnuts like I'm
ready to go home and you know make some
foods all you need you say and that's
not that's not expensive you know um so
that's what I tell people all the time
when it's like oh man it's just so
expensive and no you're really doing it
wrong if it is expensive because the
bulky bulky your calories should be
coming from like really cheap food
really really cheap food you're in
you're coming off an injury right oh yes
so you got a rough year very man yeah
what was the last race that you did
Liverpool and mate of 2017 that was like
I've done races since then but that was
the last one like I was trained for and
raced it I've done a 50k since then and
in at mount cheetah and I think it was
February in this year
but I was injured doing it like I was
like I'm just gonna get in your cutoff
I'll be fine just take all day to do so
what happened like what's the injury and
it's kind of a long road back yeah man
it's it's something that's been there
since football like I've always had this
it's the reason that us stop playing
ball in the first place and got really
fat um was I have this disc between l4
and l5 and my back that that's a severe
protrusion we know now because I've had
an MRI done since like in the past six
months or so and there's a severe
protrusion and some some canal stenosis
there and so that's there that's that's
the thing right and not only the head I
made it worse from years of you know
playing football and being morbidly
obese for decades afterwards that
afterwards but then my hobby that I
picked up once I lose the weight and
everything is ultra marathoner and then
not only ultra marathoner but running
really fast - on top of that in I really
after my hundred mile race would I've
spent so much time thinking about how I
hurt myself right but after my hundred
mile race I got into training for
Liverpool because runners were sending
me to Liverpool and another thing and so
I wanted to do that
Boston training I wanted to get fast new
is gonna take me a long time I get
faster yeah so I wanted to hurry up and
start running and I started training
probably three weeks after my hundred
mile er not enough time and it just got
worse and worse and the closer I got to
the race the more I was ignoring my back
pain and BJ knew who she was like but
she knew what I was doing she knew that
I was just trying to make it through
Liverpool you know but it was rough and
I'm and I was like I can I can grit it
out I know I'm in good shape I've been
working really hard and man between the
plane ride because we flew flew over
there on Thursday late Thursday I raced
on Sunday and a flew home Monday uh-huh
and and and and so what happened I mean
now since you're back see stuff on you
you can I was like crippled man for
months just couldn't
my back was on fire I couldn't be sleep
so I wasn't healing it was just one and
then I was trying to get back to running
every time I would make a little bit of
progress I was trying to hurry up and
get back to running because I had hired
I just never took enough time off yeah
so I made all the 2017 was like it was I
kept reinjure in myself I know now I
kept I kept going back to early I kept
going back to early and running too fast
and then getting in the hills and trying
to do vert and trying to get ready for a
mountain hundred mile and so it kept
knocking me back down and at the same
time I'm still going through a bunch of
emotional stuff because I'm fighting
through all of it because the pain is
bad mm-hmm when it hurts me it's bad
like it's it's really bad so where are
you out now right now I am yoga has been
a life changer I've been doing yoga at
least three four times a week uh-huh for
a few months now that has been a
monumental I'm feeling amazing my
mileage is back up this is about my six
or eight thirty-five plus mile week I'm
starting to run hard again but yeah I
still have some pressure back there and
I feel something going on but I'm trying
to live with it what do I need to do you
know in my practice in my power to not
have surgery what it was that mean for
me to I need to run faster do I need to
run slower do I need to run shorter what
what is what is it that I need to adjust
in my life to be able to keep doing my
thing without making that blow up
because that is diff that's a difficult
thing to get through man yeah it's a
different kind of just to see what
people give up and go get surgery like
yeah I mean not that people not that
it's giving up but my mom the reason I'm
so averse to surgeries my mom has an 18
inch steel rod in her back from severe
scoliosis and I watched her suffer with
the like after effects of back surgery
her whole life and she's railed against
it and when they want they suggested and
in football shoes I know you just don't
play football anymore
and and so it's been that's not an
option
unless it's has to be yeah and there's I
don't know when she had her surgery but
I'm sure there's been I'm sure yeah you
know I've always been like hesitant of
of it at all for that for boys I've seen
you last
the last option so but it's really it's
not it's not purely it's a bad is it you
know from everybody who's looked at it
this like you know it should be operated
on yesterday uh-huh and do you do any
kind of cairo like yes I had hanging
upside down and the decompression and
all I had was a mate I found a guy in
down the body a little bit from
Thibodeau well actually a high school
buddy of my running friend my really
good buddy JT that runs with me all the
time and um man it has been he does it
different like so all of it you I would
normally go and I just get just getting
cracked from head to toe break off crack
all my hops and he does a different ways
he's like he just finds the most out of
alignment thing or the most he calls a
primary and he'll just do that one
adjustment and then we'll come back in
48 hours or so and see see what's next
and that approach mixed with my yoga and
and having a coach helped me stay calm
and stop going so damn hard so early hey
I didn't get faster until I slowed down
so you really should slow down chill out
man relax
yeah so I had someone who I trusted
telling me that so those things combined
I'm in a much better place right now so
much so I'm feeling like feeling like
actually racing again you know um so I
have some stuff on them on the horizon
and I'm looking forward you picked it if
you picked a race yeah well I have a 50k
I've already signed up for but it's in
February but I'm gonna go back to the
first one I ever did that woman Dustin I
didn't want a Destin on the beach that
was the one we talked about it in 2015
but me and my buddies who did that race
we're gonna go back
to it now they've been knocking out 100
miles like crazy since then I've only
done one you know and they just smash it
on me one of those done a tour duty
since then and oh yeah people like oh
man I can't believe you front office I'm
like man I'm the weakest off your honor
of all of our friends guide like led the
charge well it's I'm glad to hear about
the kyra war and you know people give
Cairo [ __ ] but like it's it's done a lot
for me yeah it's been super beneficial
you know I have some lower back pain
stuff I'm spondee and you know like some
curved spine so I have to stay on top of
that and one of the things that that
that my guy had me start doing which I
definitely need to do more consistently
than I do is something called the
Foundation series you heard about this I
know look it up on youtube so Siri it's
like a 10-minute little routine that you
can do every single day of like super
simple just static
you know postures yeah help with
alignment that that sounds interesting
because I find myself like doing things
intuitively it would be nice to maybe
have something like some specific
direction yeah Oh cuz I can feel like
when I'm driving I can feel that but I
can feel my pelvis getting looser and I
my sacrum cuz I went to this guy in New
York when I was long is so crazy how the
universe works this I went to the Good
Morning America show right I want to get
into that with you yeah it's so wild but
anyway while I was up there Howard has a
friend who put me in touch with another
friend he had another friend and then
like three friends later I'm in touch
with this like body worker fellow in in
in Manhattan mm-hmm and so I was like I
was in touch with him via text message
and I said I'm gonna come he said this
is right on my side of the street I see
why my friends sent you here this is
right up my alley I can help you and so
I went to him and he kind of showed me
what my problem was that was a big issue
was I didn't really understand where the
pain was coming from I knew ahead the
bulging disc but that's I had paint all
in my like in my groin and in the hip
part of me and all
and so they did a lot of explaining and
gave me some exercises to do to get to
wake up my hip muscles and all cuz a lot
of stuff
I'm sure is frozen from not only running
so much but also being so fat for so
long I'm sure my pelvis is a weird yeah
shape sometimes I don't know but he
showed me how to get started moving my
body and that was the first step it
started changing and it made me go you
know what I should do yoga it made the
movements he did felt like yoga
movements I was like okay instead of
having to go to Manhattan and see him
you know I'll just start doing yoga and
see if it helps and it has been it's
been like magnificent yeah just really
open up the hips and the psoas and and
create that space yeah you know it's
like it's about like loosening it off so
there's motion in the breathing like
because I think the lungs like when you
from the inside what it does to your
spine as you eat physic as your body
physically he's in you know makes breath
you know because there's something that
happens when I'm breathing you know the
cat-cow stuff I always hear things
moving right doing cat-cow well it takes
a certain level of discipline to know
that you actually have to back off and
and you've been really good about that
like even and you know like on Strava
you still like post all your stuff but
it just feel like I want to walk ya know
and it's like yeah it was like it's okay
and you know I think for for people that
get into running and then become
obsessed with running and it's one race
after another you feel like you're
you're you know a superhuman and you
think you're never gonna hit that injury
oh praise God
but everything you've had to learn that
lesson the hard way from trying to go
back too soon which i think is a really
good thing like I feel alright like I'm
gonna go hit it again and then yes I'm
never heal yeah letting like obligation
letting a race obligation sort of push
me ahead like before I was ready I know
cuz I know I had a race on I had a race
on the horizon that's why I kept going
try to because like man I live in
there's a mountain hundred mile that I
wanted to do in September right it's
like man I don't have enough time to get
it [ __ ] if I take two more weeks I'm not
gonna be able to build my base all right
so to the two of the kind of huge media
events that occurred in your life since
the last time we spoke is and you
mentioned it you landed the cover of
Runner's World magazine which is crazy
all right
yeah and then unrelated to that really
you ended up on Good Morning America
because of this face Facebook group that
you created dogs yeah to start with the
runner's world thing yeah that was crazy
something like just a bunch of people on
social media just kept like tagging me
in this thing that this promotion that
runners roll was doing like a cover
photo contest and it wannabe and it was
a bunch of before and afters is what it
wound up being but it was that wasn't
the theme of the deal but anyway it was
just about your running story and so I
was like okay I'll do that and I'll put
my running story in there about my
especially specifically with you know
the Crescent City classic and you know
that yeah explain why that races so
because okay so I mean in the very
beginning the first race I ever did was
the 10k the Crescent City Classic in New
Orleans and it took me like an hour and
43 minutes and that race that that
distance became like a like sort of like
Oh indication of something to me like I
just wanna check that on like before
what you were still in your journey of
losing
sure that was a first one I had lost
some weight but the first one I still
waited like 330 340 something like that
in the first one that's why it took me
an hour and 40 minutes to do a 10k and
then the next year you know I so my my
story the next year I was I wanted to do
under an hour and I got that done and
that sort of set me off into trying to
like be a better runner which sent me to
you and all this other stuff and then
the neck and then the next year I wanted
to get a poster for the first time and
and this race if you there's 30,000
entrance so if you get a top 500 finish
you get a special commemorative poster
and it's like a big [ __ ] deal in New
Orleans like if you were running and you
New Orleans like you got a poster this
year that's the thing like we want to
know like where are you oh you oh you're
not a post you didn't forget a poster
okay like so this year next year right
and so I think kind of I was like
starting to get into running circles
right and starting to understand it and
I was like I wanted poster damn it and I
got a poster how many attempts 33 times
1/3 yeah I had no idea about a poster
until I was training to break 50 minutes
in the third room that's what I was
really wanting to do and the third one
was the break 50 minutes but what wound
up happening is uh I broke like 40 I ran
46 and change and a training run and
then the people that I ran that with
said dude you should probably try to get
a poster this year yeah and then he's
like if you could run sub 45 you could
probably get a poster so that third year
around forty 308 so I was like an hour
in three years yeah but since then I
broke forty minutes for the first time
Howard came down and he he wanted a
poster he's like I think I could run
fast enough to get a poster and and he
did he got a postive man he got a top
550 got one way it was hot that year a
lot of people fell off and he wound up
finishing 40
we 5:15 I'm getting the poster I broke I
got thirty I ran 39:55 and that's still
my 10k prpr yeah and so into in the
context of like this runner's world
story that so just I shared that shared
that sort of continuum about my running
in a more abbreviated version obviously
for the to fit the contest rules and
I've showed and I shared a before
picture of me and asked my friends on
social media to vote for me and um and I
didn't see the vote totals getting up
really high sorry and I think anything
would ever happen but it turns out the
votes were just like a tiny part of what
they were really how they were really
gonna choose the thing you know so they
had Bart Yasso and the chat eeeh the
editor-in-chief of runner's world and
mr. Jin whether like the CEO of Brooks
and they just sort of really kind of
went through all the stories and picked
the top ten and brought all ten of us in
yeah I'm still friends with all of them
we got to go Ronny and yeah like a photo
shoot yeah and then and then after that
they were like okay so then it was like
the final thing and then he picked who
the girl winner was and the guy when it
was yeah you know and I wouldn't I know
it was I was like I was beside myself I
couldn't imagine what is that like to go
you know to a newsstand or you know to
see that magazine on it you know sitting
around somewhere it's funny like I wrote
cuz I can't even compute yeah okay it's
a runner's world and I'm on the cover I
mean I it almost doesn't even seem like
real it's um
it's powerful I feel proud of myself in
ways I've never felt proud of myself
before in my entire life and it's almost
like a in bloom it's almost like a look
I didn't just lose weight you did this
mmm-hmm but what I get from you is it's
not a hey look at me no it's it's a
symbol of like all this journey like all
the work that
put in to completely transform yourself
from this you know person that you were
yeah into this person that you are today
it's like it's like a totem right it
just it represents that shift you know
it's not like hey how many people read
the magazine it's like it's like it's
just an acknowledgement and that's what
that's exactly right
it's being like people going being
acknowledged for something that people
think I did that has value right to to
to others which that's that's like you
know that's powerful to feel like you're
valuable to someone or valuable to lots
of people
mm-hmm just because of what you've been
through do you find that that the flip
side of that is that now suddenly people
who like a big part of your whole thing
is like you're very relatable like
people can connect with you because
you're like a dude right right but
suddenly you're on the cover of a
magazine yeah maybe not so relatable you
know well Josh did that but like look
he's on the cover of magazines he's all
fancy-pants now you know yeah that's not
my life yeah I know it's tricky but it's
if once people I guess meet me they they
they uh they can understand that's why I
try to stay so raw in on my social media
I really don't like because that way
people do understand it I'm not any I'm
just a normal person right
you know you'd going on ramp like 4:00
in the morning in your trunk yeah
exactly
I'm just a normal dude there's nothing
really special about me like results are
typical if you apply you know the power
of plants to your life and the power of
bipedal locomotion and getting outside
and getting some sunshine and using this
human body the way it was intended to be
used and loved some body man I mean it's
pretty simple and to be really damn
happy
it's a shame is such a secret all right
Josh like I I get it I'm inspired by
like does it have to
like the plant-based thing like I'm
hearing a lot of good stuff about this
low-carb diet maybe I'm gonna go keto
like what's the deal with the plants
like why is that the truck for you the
thing is I think you would agree to it
nutrients are very important in our diet
and there's no more nutrient dense way
to eat than a heavily plant-based diet
so we don't let's not even call it
plants let's just say we're gonna eat a
nutrient-rich diet that's high in fiber
and very calorically dilute because
we're trying to lose weight right now
now if you can do that with some
hamburger meat show me show me how we do
that but we need these things to do the
thing you say you want so if you say you
want that this is what we have to do if
you do otherwise then you're not
choosing the thing you say you want so
you got some work to do you're lying to
yourself a little bit and I don't know
how to help you I can only show you some
some you know some data and tell you
what I did and help you through the
thing but ultimately it's up to you use
your plate as a volume knob on potential
disease or current disease is something
mm-hmm how is your approach your diet
evolved since the first time that we
talked like what have you learned how
has it changed how if you dialed it in
got it's gotten really simple it's
gotten a lot simpler since then less I
do lots more savory for breakfast than I
used to I used to do lots of um oats and
fruit and things like that
not that that's bad it's just uh it's
not my thing I'm much rather a good warm
bowl of real soupy white beans over some
kale uh-huh
you know big giant ass bowl of that
after a long run in the morning after a
good eight nine mile six eight mile run
in the morning um that is where that's
what I want after my run so you know
getting simpler having savory pretty
much all the time I don't really I don't
do a whole lot of sweet I do I do like
apples for snacks and things like that
but when it comes down to sit down and
eat
miel it's almost every single mule it's
gonna be something hot and savory and
that's simple
just keep something against the pot and
do different things with it as I eat it
and you cook all your meals pretty much
during the week for sure on the weekends
when my wife and I and our puppies in
New Orleans we go to our our favorite
you know plant-based joints in in the
city but most the time yeah we just cook
our own stuff we we have aunts the pot
on the spawn of it I mean on the counter
and BJ she makes amazing black beans she
does awesome red lentils with some
Ethiopian spices in it and stuff and
we'll have like one of three things for
the week and on the wrong it just stays
hot it's the part you know and she's she
she didn't originally she wasn't on on
the same page as you know the beginning
right so where's she at now she's on
she's on she's on the board and what is
that what is that been like it's amazing
cuz she's on her own little world of
like sort of growing her own curiosity
in different directions for mine so like
fasting and just different things and
she's dabbling in that stuff and
teaching me about it is you know so it's
it's less about like being plant-based
per se and more about like being being
curious about where I would like to grow
what I would like to experiment with you
know and that's as a couple like that's
really fun too that's really fun to
engage in at what point did she kind of
click in to this though cuz at first it
was just this is your trip right yeah
yeah she um she she still doesn't like
she's not gonna want to beat on any of
my social media post next with 100% guys
T that's clear that's clear I was there
was a moment where I was like she's
still married
is everything okay you know oh
everything you know great all right good
and it's because she's not on my social
media yeah everything is great she's not
a fan of her because of her before
pictures for sure so but yeah she she
didn't see the need at first to get rid
of like her she's like yeah get rid of
me that's gross she's been after me like
she would never obtain cold deer meat
and I would have to trick her into
eating and making it heart-shaped
patties or something so you have to
guilt her into eat it and uh but when I
got rid of the meat it wasn't that big
of a deal for her but the the dairy and
stuff but yeah watching folks over
knives changed that for her and then she
moved she moved forward and not only
does she do it and go all in as a
registered nurse she saw the she saw the
science she understood it it made really
good sense to her and like she says once
I knew it I couldn't Unknowing you know
and so now she's a you know she's an
employer herself and and she's got 30
employees lots of them are nurses and
nurses aides and stuff and so like her
assistant is plant-based the her um her
partner in the in the in the business is
plant-based now older
oh he's older than us he's not old at
all but he's just an older guy he's
older than us and he's like I didn't
even know I had 30 pounds to lose we
bought him eat to live for Christmas one
year yeah and he's like oh my god I'm
off all of my mat I'm all following my
statins I lost 30 pounds that even
though I had 30 pounds lose I feel like
I'm gonna live forever it's like so
she's being infectious in her little
community as well like her little yeah
median environment and they got she's
got old people is so adorable she she's
a baby I'm taking the Vitamix to work
today I got some miss so-and-so miss you
know Boudreau wants a green smoothie she
wants me to show her how to make one you
know so that's that's fine man yes
so when people approach you and say you
know I I want to do this but you know I
have a partner that isn't on the same
page or isn't you know isn't it isn't
supportive I mean as somebody who has
had a little bit of an evolution in your
own relationship with that like what is
the kind of advice that you can give to
that person just you know you got you
got an exhibit consistency on your and
if you really want it to happen you have
to exhibit it you have to do it and you
have to be willing to accept that that
person may never ever do it mmm and and
you're gonna have to love them through
that and luckily I didn't have to go
past that step luckily I didn't have to
figure out how to do it with someone in
the house that isn't on the same page as
me
luckily um BJ you know was a pragmatist
and saw the same thing I saw and jumped
right on board with me but I I feel I
get frustrated with I hear a lot of the
the husbands who are who are like you
know women who have type 2 diabetics who
this could reverse that and fix it but
they gotta go home here I don't want to
do all that vegan [ __ ] you better cook
me some steak and macaroni yeah that's
so dumb that's not mainly at all you
know and to hear those stories from
ladies we're trying to help is like dog
it's tough it's weird it's bizarre that
our sense of what it means to be a man
is is is oddly tied up in what foods we
choose to eat when you really think
about it it doesn't make any sense but
that's the fact that's the truth that's
the way our culture function is
reinforced with constant advertising I
think it didn't you even post something
the other day about like somebody who
was it was it you owe me it was me my
he's like I watched an NFL game like
every ad you know was reinforcing this
is a masculine stereotype that you have
to eat these certain foods or your your
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes
yes exactly right and so that is not
leading us in a positive direction in
terms of health when you consider the
fact that one out of every three people
suffers a heart attack from heart
disease yeah and I mean you know
honestly I don't know if the ribs aren't
tibideaux but they're probably higher
bad yeah it's what we would say I mean
you can't give me a typical like a
snapshot of you know what it looks like
down there in terms of okay so just I'll
just walk you through our locker room
like in so in a Wellness Center we have
I would say just a rough guess a good
half and I'm being generous here of all
the guys that are going in a gym I love
them I'm not picking on them but at
least half of them or would be
technically morbidly obese and I would
say maybe more of them who are my age or
older or on statins you know and some of
them are having dialysis cuz they've had
they I don't know what what you've had
so long that you wind up needing
dialysis but I have a buddy I talk to
all the time who he's losing weight now
but it's because he is so diseased so
whether you go to Walmart you go to
rouses or people riding in buggies and
people always talking about the next
heart attack or the last heart attack or
the cancer that a god or the that's
ubiquitous man disease is ubiquitous and
especially on the body so much so it's a
normal it's normal
hmm and when it becomes normal yeah then
there's then it just feels like there's
no need to do any like if ever if
everybody's in your predicament mm-hmm
then there's no urgency to change yep
yeah and but it's book in the only way
honestly that someone like me is will is
willing to are able to go against the
grain in that environment is because I
know I have people that have my back
that are really smart they might live in
California or they might live in North
Carolina
I'm not all alone and me being able to
have that confidence to stand in a place
of vulnerability among the people I know
where I speak the language in order to
sort of win some some you know some sort
of influence in having their ear for
just a second right you know that's
that's powerful yeah when you look at
the kind of conversations that are
happening online around health and diet
and nutrition you know I don't know
about you but it's pretty toxic a lot of
people yelling at each other
yeah throwing you know epithets at each
other yeah you know whether it's you
know vegans against the low-carb people
and the ketosis people on the
intermittent fasting PETA there's all
these camps right everybody's got the
same goal how can we improve health in
America across the world we have
different ideas about how to do that
but the level of communication that is
taking place right now has devolved into
this mudslinging affair whereby nobody
is benefiting nobody's listening to each
other and certainly the people who need
the most help are not able to hear any
of it and I think that reinforces a
paralysis it keeps people stuck in their
habits that are no longer serving them
and you know big you know big thing that
I've been spending a lot of time
thinking about is how to how to
transcend that like how to have better
communication how to have better
conversations how to really understand
where other people are coming from so
that you can find an effective way to
have a conversation that perhaps could
have a positive impact and I think it
starts with empathy hmm it starts with
you know sort of taking a beat maybe
letting go of whatever Dogma you're
holding on to and why it's so
emotionally charged for you yeah and
just pausing to try to understand
somebody else and I see you as somebody
who's been very effective at taking
these tools that have transferred
your life that you've learned from
people who live outside the bio coming
home and finding a way to translate them
into a way that can incite positive
change in other people so when you look
at that dialogue at that conversation
that's either happening online or or
even you know in communities
face-to-face with certain people like
how do you think about that what is your
opinion on that and how could we do
better well I keep I think if we just
keep having a conversation even when
it's ugly even when it's gross even when
it feels like mudslinging whatever it is
let's be consistently talking about it
let's keep pushing the let's keep
pushing the snowball up the hill but you
know I think what lacks and a lot of all
of the talk that I'm participating in
myself and witness and read online is a
lot of sincerity is what is missing you
know I think if we approach with a lot
more even if we're wrong in something if
we're truly sincere about trying to
convey something of value to someone I
think we are headed in the right
direction the reason is I mean I have
words with people online you mix it up
because this is not playtime for me this
is I'm not selling Herbalife of
something hmm
this is not what we do in here bro this
is not what we do in here we're doing so
I am talking about something I'm talking
about grabbing and grabbing a machete
and going after something that I know
now took my grandmother away at 67 years
old made my grandfather miserable for
the last few years of his life you know
I know that it's it's a it's it's a
beast
and so I'm not playing it's not a joke
to me and so I don't mind speaking out
so I I don't think it should be unicorns
and lollipops this this the context of
this nutritional
whatever you want to call it this battle
that's happening online sometimes but I
do think that it likes a lot of
sincerity I think a lot of people are
faking the funk and preaching at people
before they even have a foothold on [ __ ]
themselves and that's where a lot of the
noise comes from you know but being
Frank and real with somebody is needed
as long as it comes from a sincere place
and I don't mind apologizing if I was
incorrect but I'm but I'm gonna try and
speak my mind try and try and stay to
what I think and know is real is my
world and if I'm wrong tell me I want to
know if I'm wrong
yeah well I mean I think you you
accomplished that I mean you're
unbelievably real and authentic and how
you you know share your your unique
experience and and and what you've gone
through and how you've gotten to where
you're at right now and one of the one
of the kind of things that you've done
that that really stood out to me was
that time that you that you took some
pictures of you without your shirt on
with all the extra skin yeah and down
he's like this is the truth of what
happens when you go from 420 or whatever
you know where you're at right now like
you're gonna look like me my you know
Dom's like I tell every time Dom's
poster should like or even Garth they
posted a picture without a shirt on uh
so I put on a shirt man hey y'all
killing me because you're sitting across
from me right now for Hitler just
listening to this you're you're jacked
you got your guns on you also had you go
at like of stretch marks yeah you know I
have this these things my body has gone
through a lot and even with all of this
even with all of this it's not it's so
much less worse than I imagined it when
I was 420 pounds because I was like even
imagine if I lost all the weight how
much extra skin I would have I remember
getting my first stretch marks worn my
way to get fat it ruined my whole summer
it ruined my month my uh my senior trip
we were in Cancun and I took my shirt
off and I was about to go to the beach
with all of my friends and I passed by
the mirror and
bathroom and I saw stretch marks down my
side and I was hot
what were you pushing then oh and oh I
was probably 300 pounds right but it was
the stretch marks that got you the
stretch marks got me and so I made up
the fact that I was bored and I didn't I
wasn't enjoying the trip and I played
like a fuddy dudd just to avoid going on
the beach with my friends mmm it made
everybody mad at me you know mm-hmm
so this skin has been around for a long
time and I've also in and still like on
that say hey what it looks like right
and then also understand though the skin
is an organ and it's alive you know and
it's constantly adapting so I'm in
process like where is it now compared to
where it was at two years ago oh God
really really good right does it
contract States better and better but my
what body fat I have left is held really
loosely and flabbily like around my
belly button I don't know if that'll
ever go anywhere I mean I don't see a
whole lot of like X like people who've
lost 230 pounds doing shirtless cover
shoots yeah um so I don't know I don't
know if there's examples of that without
surgery without cutting it off of yeah
so you could go to Beverly Hills and
snip it all yeah we're gonna skip down
so that I better just put some effort
into being pretty damn okay with it and
when I think about it especially when I
look at it against my clothes right cuz
my clothes are so huge I know you save
some of that you share something about
that the other day like you put on one
of your old Jessie way I want people to
think about yeah I look weird a little
bit but the thing is think it because
it's mostly heavy people that are asking
me this question it's like you're so
worried about looking as bad as you
think I look under my shirt that you're
scared to lose 200 pounds how silly is
now it's a crazy it's crazy
oh but yeah you think about the shirt
though the extra material one of five or
six extra-large some of my t-shirts with
six extra large and
you think about the extra material in a
shirt and you compare that to what extra
material I have in skin on my body my
body did pretty damn good right it's
doing base winning yeah there's more
there's more cotton than there is right
yeah so what was that what was the
reaction when you posted that it was it
was it was it was heartwarming it was
nice there were comments that people
make that think they're being you know
supportive that it this one bothers me
and I hope I don't offend anybody who
said it who's it because a lot of people
say it so it's not like one person but
I'll post something like that and they
tell me how brave I am and I don't feel
brave at all like this is like that's
almost confirming that I look bad to
tell me how brave it is of me well it
takes courage to be vulnerable like yeah
I guess to do that is a is a is is is to
put yourself in a vulnerable position I
guess so but it can't help how it feels
when I read it you know what I'm saying
cuz it still doesn't land right yeah it
doesn't land now it's like oh if I
looked like that I could never take off
my shirt that's the way I read it you
know right but that's just third layer
than me there that it's just it's yeah
people are there just look man it's
still a lot of like stuff I work through
day every single day of thoughts that
are twisted that I'm untwisting still
you know getting offended when I
probably shouldn't have been and like
I'm still learning well let's talk about
that person let's talk about that
because the the weight loss thing is
just to surf that's on the surface sure
that's what everyone wants to talk about
how to do that but you know what are the
changes that have happened emotionally
like you know what is this this
spiritual trajectory that you're on like
where are you at with all of that how
has that changed or evolved the last
couple of years yeah never like I was
really religious when I was a kid well I
wasn't really just my family was my
grandmother was the daughter of a
Baptist minister my mom BAM Bam's wife
and so it was Church twice on Sunday
we're going on Wednesday night and I
grew up in a very Protestant right-wing
Baptist environment and in a lot of ways
I've railed against the hypocrisy I saw
as a kid you know cuz I know the behind
stuff go behind closed door stuff that
happens and then all the stuff that
happens during fellowship at church all
right and so moved away from that as
I've grown older in my life and although
I'm not religious at all I see where
religion come is coming from you know I
see what is trying to get it the more I
move forward and and maybe it's just
from getting older but that spirituality
means something bigger to me than
anything religion could ever encapsulate
you know and it's so simple
it's so much simpler than all of those
rules and things and really surrendering
to just living you know an authentic
life for myself that helped that was
that simple little phrase really helps
free up a mind you know you know to
unlock and unleash a more first
authentic self and that in and of itself
like your self-love that's your religion
that's religion that's how you thank God
for your existence and I'm glad to have
like come across that you know and I'm
because it I feel fulfilled I feel whole
and I feel like when when you're in that
place even though I have tons of [ __ ] to
deal with all and still to that's not
fun but I feel complete and then you
feel like being of service for other
people what's that that continuing with
learn one do one teach one well the
feeling of completeness comes from the
giving back anything and over and over
from you yeah this is something that
you've like really taken on you know
like you really you really have
made this commitment to make your life
about giving back this gift that's been
given to you in your community and you
know this the Facebook group you're
wearing the wristband for the missing
Gio's club I'll give you what I don't
really I never got big enough to have a
second chance maybe a little dip right
so when did you start that and how did
that like lead you to Good Morning
America well that's a fun story because
like so you put me out in a social media
world and then like so then people
started connecting with me and other
people who had lost big weight we're
like oh I lost weight too and I'm on a
plant-based diet - and my name is
so-and-so and let's be friends and so
that's sort of happened and you
accumulate all of my friends they
Anthony Massey yellows and the Jason
Cohens and you know all of my buddies
that Tim Kaufman my you know fat man
rants and all these people that I was
connecting with individually I was like
man we should all be in the same place
and I didn't want it to be something
that we were gonna like turn into a
Facebook page and sell t-shirts about
and like because there were ideas about
doing it that way and I just sort of
said no I want to do let's just do a
secret Facebook group of just us and we
get to talk about our stretch marks and
our deflated man boobs and how difficult
it is people don't understand what it's
like to train for a marathon when you
got you know extra kid skin flapping
around at you got to make sure you get
the right type of compression shorts for
so you don't yeah those conversations
like the audience while you're honest
you're afraid to talk to him right with
the only god Zach might be able so
that's all it started it was like maybe
20 of us uh-huh and one of those guys in
that group is as Eric oh great he's so
he's a he's a missing chin you know you
familiar what his story would be and so
Eric said hey man this is really cool I
have a friend that works for one as well
I think he would like to do an article
on it and that was it and so Eric Eric
sent sent the idea to his friend at
runner's world and then they did an
article on the missing Chin's they came
down all the ones that live
geographically close enough to me they
showed up we did a photo shoot and
Peltier parking timid Oh secret groups
not so secretly great all said but we
like that the writer get access to the
see was on the page I get I got
permission from the guy because I did I
and I and I'll include the men but I
also did for the girl that was a that
she was producing for the GM it for Good
Morning America so what happened was
after the after the runner's world thing
People magazine picked it up and did a
similar story and then after that I was
just laying around hurting really bad my
back was bothering me and um and I was
depressed and I get a phone call and
almost didn't answer because I didn't
recognize the number and it was a lady
she got one too yeah I don't know anyone
in two ways so she's like hey I'm so so
a good more in America I was like okay
we would like to see if you would like
to do a story if you'd be even
interested and I was like yeah so
ultimately I just kept you know how
those things go and email a million and
you you get guys hopes up because they
think they want to do one thing and it's
like you're the bad guy because you're
delivering these crazy messages is like
you think I think I'm gonna be able to
get all of you guys to come and then you
owe only these guys can come although
you got to swap it around they want this
now they wanted to be and so being the
messenger and getting people
disappointed and excited that would that
part kind of suck but that's all that
happened was they read about the missing
Chin's and then they they it was an
inspirational story for the end of the
year and so they asked us to put
together to come and if we'd be willing
to come up and so that's what it was I
called a few guys from around the the
country to represent like a wide swath
right how many how many people are part
of that group that's that point at that
point Oh probably a hundred a hundred
yeah and they were like what like nine
of you or something like that that that
showed up for the segment um there was a
group of like no I don't ever sick yeah
it was just like yeah just I think it
was just five of us
I think it was just five oh so good
morning yeah yeah tripping and I just
saw I watched it I was just thinking
about what was going through your mind
talking to Strahan I wanted to talk
someplace no I got to remind him about a
about a 40 burger that the Saints put on
his defense the year he retired and he
was like oh ha remember he said I've
been trying to forget that I've been
trying to forget about that game since I
retired you know but it was his it was
his last game in the dome I think if
they won the Super Bowl that year so
ultimately he's lucky yeah he wins but
they got their ass handed to him in the
dome right I think for me it was
emotional seeing you on television
because unlike the runners world thing
like this was this was about like
something that you helped to build that
wasn't about you yeah you know and
that's really what it's about
like how can you scale beyond your own
personal achievements in a way that can
impact people positively for the
long-term mm-hmm and it was a
recognition of that again like a
symbolic thing it's not about like being
on Good Morning America it's like
culture is recognizing that that that
not just that you created this thing but
that there are opportunities for a
better way forward to address these
problems that so many people have yeah
and these guys you I mean look rich
you'd be so proud of like they come
together and come to each other's aid
like they'll start group messages and
raise money for each other to help each
other by like buy what they need I go I
don't have a running watch I'm gonna
saving up we'll see
and then we'll like either don't and we
have like a thing like when when one of
the chins is about to get rid of if he
buys a new watch and he'll and it's a
watch that he wants to just give away or
just post and say who wants it in the
first got it asked for it just send it
to them in the mail like it's a real
deep Pat gets a community it's it's a
it's tight-knit and you know we had a
hundred people for Good Morning America
I don't think we have more than 200
because how many invites solicitations
did you get after that tons man but the
thing is it's secret so it's hard for
people to find it unless they find us
they gotta go look at the video put
remember how to spell our names and then
go find us on social media and message
us and ask us and give us a little story
about themselves and convinces that they
deserve or not deserve but belong with
us in our group you know so it's a
barrier to entry on purpose because we
want the right people want you really
looking how to find us uh-huh and when
you do almost what's that what's the
weirdest thing that you guys have had a
chat about on that group oh my god this
guy was trying to raise money would a
GoFundMe or something and it felt fishy
and awkward and so one of the guys like
researched his name and it turned out he
had done like this GoFundMe fraud before
and so we start calling him out like he
was trying to use the missing Qin's Club
okay everyone daffodility like sorry the
sob story
like he was trying to do that and then
when we called him out he went off
calling us like like like some of the
nicest old got like we got some older
fellows in there that are struggling and
trying to get this [ __ ] together and and
I just be like he just went off like
what talking about wanna kill everybody
and like it was crazy it was the so we
had all kind of little messages gone
like who is this guy what is going on
he's the only person that we've had to
block you had to banish yeah that's the
lone case Wow and what is a what are
some of the success stories um so my
buddy Adam brown is one of my favorite
he's this a you know redheaded kid from
the sticks I think up in I'm sorry Adam
it's Illinois or Pennsylvania he's up
from up north somewhere right and
anything north of Georgia
and you a redneck I don't know so it's
so so yeah so Adam he lives up in the
sticks he lives in the woods just like
we do so he came down for the Louisiana
Marathon ate the Louisiana Marathon gave
us a bunch of free entries gave us like
20 entries for the marathon or half
whatever you wanted just fought mr.
Chen's buddies and so he drove down to
take advantage of one of those this guy
Adam and he we talked and we talked he
was just getting started with his
plant-based stuff he was I think
pre-diabetic or type 2 not sure but he
was overweight and but he hunted and he
lived in the country and he had all of
these identity things that my story
really resonated with him you know and
what if for whatever reason his his
mindset clicked he kept he stayed
consistent he kept trying I could tell
when I talked to him at the marathon he
was really skeptical about believing he
could do it
you know now I get it cuz I've been
there and now I haven't worked without
him at all I haven't done [ __ ] Adam has
just done it all on his own but just
being a part of this organic community
where he just passively gets information
and inspiration since then he's lost a
whole bunch of weight I don't know how
much but it's pretty impressive to see
his before and after and it's and he's
got it he's when it's clicked oh he gets
how simple it is and now just like Tim
coughing man and and like all these
other guys Anthony Masiello and myself
it's it's automatic and it's gravity and
now it's his just taking up the balls
went downhill
it's my decibel mentally and a little
taste it's not just sunrise another guy
so it's a crazy story I have a buddy who
lives right next to me named Jason and
Jason is from Philly right but he lives
in Schriever Louisiana and so jason has
a so jason has lost a lot of weight and
because he's so close to me we've run
together before and we've gotten
together online and he he's been he
fought with low carb for years and wound
up going plant-based and it helped him a
lot with his with his weight loss and so
he was trying to talk to his buddy Jeff
up and in
Fillie hey his buddy was really
overweight you should join the missing
Chen's with us we're gonna help you out
and Jeff struggle man Jeff was he came
in and he always had questions but it
was a lot of self-deprecation in his way
he was asking questions soon we'd even
really answered her questions most the
time we just talked about the self
deprecating home and just made you a bad
son of a [ __ ] but what you're talking
about get up get your head together
and so you know over time jeff has lost
100 pounds I saw him he I didn't even
recognize his clothes all [ __ ] baggy
and stuff is so crazy he I saw at
Leadville he just comes to Leadville and
he's got just jump shorts and a regular
white t-shirt and then all his stuff is
bagging he's like man hundred pounds man
and he's all excited about it you know
Kevin there's a there's I can go on
there's dudes on the body there's dudes
right there in Thibodaux that are in
this thing you know and they're they're
they're plant-based they're not like all
out in the world about it they don't
want to be Josh about it like I'm doing
this because I was inspired to by a
mentor of mine not everybody has to go
and get on a microphone and you do the
thing your weight do your thing but
there's a lot of guys that are you know
changing they get it it's they get it
they see the power and then they're
deciding how much of it they willing to
take right now and they take bite after
bite and I think the bites get bigger as
they go you know the community piece is
so so important that's all they talked
about a plant Rishon this weekend it was
so massive that's the sauce man for the
projection eulogy in Mass yes the
connectivity the feeling like it you're
not doing it alone if there's somebody
who can answer your questions there's
somebody who will hold you accountable
there's somebody who will pat you on the
back and you know I think culturally
we've we've just you just live lives way
more isolated than we were genetically
wired to do we need that you know we
need that to move forward I think that's
a huge part of why we've slid so far
down this rabbit hole
disease and for health man because we're
not connected we're not being held
accountable yeah and we can in and from
me the first thing that really sparked
my community or my desire for newer
community was becoming a runner and
doing my very first run group it is you
you know people dismiss me when I talk
about the running and it like as if it's
just a calorie burning activity it's not
exercise this is how we do it this is
how we did we're pack animals we would
move by pili in in like groups man this
is what we do this is what Chi and this
is why hard what I was talking about
with Sanjay were what exactly yeah dad I
had to pause that one halfway through so
I could finish buffering my brother like
my eyes were rolling you haven't seen
the movie yet I have no I have not you
love it
yes all right gosh I have to what else
was going on at plant Rishon well you
know the normal line up of all stars
really cool stuff because of you people
you know coming up to me like that was
that was a really surreal thing we we
had a booth you know the hour well start
thing in Howard and yeah I remember that
yeah sure and but we had that and people
these doctors are coming up and talking
to me and I'm like a little apprehensive
to talk to a doctor about something
about my expertise right but a lot of
them would come up to me and want to
take a picture of me because they knew
about me from you right oh you wants one
of my favorite podcasts I tell my
patients about you all the time I got
that at least and I'm not exaggerating
rich at least eight times this weekend
yeah well as a target-rich environment
of course is like high concentration or
let's bury no yeah no it's great he's
long me too it's awesome it's pretty
cool to be right you know that you know
the last time we did the first time we
did the podcast was 2013 mmm-hmm you
know yeah that struck a chord it was a
Skype call I'm sure I haven't gone back
and listened to it I mean I'm sure
audios terrible I had no idea but it was
so powerful that it just transcends all
of that nonsense and the fact that
people are still discovering a
conversation that we had literally five
years ago and then followed up three
years ago is insane yeah you know it
feels awesome to be part like you know
to be part of that conversation that
that is such a gift that I don't and I
know a follower myself you know always
thanking you for but it's just the truth
and it's just such a gifted like I'm
just this guy from check me and I'm not
like I was raised in a trailer park
dude I'm nothing special and to have you
say oh look at this guy what he holds
value man that's huge for me the story
is super powerful and I would say to you
what you tell people in your face group
Facebook group like why you you know why
you why you denigrating yourself in that
way because what you did is
extraordinary the way you did it perhaps
even more extraordinary and it would be
a crime had you not made that decision
to share your story because it's it's a
pilot light man it is a catalyst for so
many people out there who are struggling
who just need a lifeline who need to
find somebody that they can connect with
and we all have our various ways of
carrying this torch and I know that you
know I can reach certain people but
there's a huge swath of people that
can't relate to me that can relate to
you and and you know that's why it's so
powerful the the vibration that you're
carrying and so I'm not surprised that
people are still you know saying that
that was impactful for them but you're
the one just like in the way that you
decided to get to work and put those
running shoes on and you know commit to
this lifestyle change and then to give
it back like you're the one who's done
the work and shown up to build this
thing that you've built that has brought
you to you know places like the plant
Rishon project and connected you with
people like Howard and
and to this well start yeah project that
you're working on and this book that
you're writing so like tell me about
what's going on with that yeah that's it
all started just because you know
another another sort of nudge from you
about getting my story in a book and
like to really pursue that that should
be something that I should be working
towards so I took that to heart and I'm
in a rope I wrote a lot I wrote a lot
and I put together everything I could
think of and a very raw sort of
manuscript that I mean it was tons and
tons of my life and deep dark stuff that
I've never really told a lot of people
and I didn't know really what to do with
it you know but met up with Garth the
year after you were at health fest and
Garth put me in touch with with Howard
long story short right now Jacob
salaries or sound on the podcast a long
time yeah yeah in his podcast what you
was powerful for me and it sent me down
the road to go read whole which the way
things were put in hole was really
something that meant it really lends
itself to being okay with surrender the
way hole is couched you know so it's so
complicated forget about it back up back
up let's just seed Whole Foods and I got
that and that was a huge thing and so to
have the off the co author of that book
contact me via Facebook message and said
thank you for accepting my friendship
request I was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me haha yeah and so we just
struck up a conversation on messenger
and then we had a phone call and then
one thing led to the next and it's like
I have a whole bunch of stuff that I
rolled how it's ready to like move to
the buyer yeah and how it's so next
thing you know it's like I'm he said
well I think maybe the next step is we
should meet each other and I was like
yeah so you know over the years Howard
and I have just become like brothers man
just like in that that that last podcast
with you I said I've never had a big
brother now like I have multiple big
brothers people who are literally like I
look up to like I would look up to a big
brother
and like I've shared deep things with
Howard and spent long long conversations
and so
we've got really really close and he
knows a lot about me and he knows a lot
about what went into me being able to
get traction and he knows what's
important along the way in my in my
journey you know and he's just a
brilliant writer and so Howard has been
able to from writing my helping me you
know get together with all of the stuff
that I wrote plus writing what-what he
added to it to make it better write all
of that stuff in doing that practice at
the same time we worked on this coaching
platform because how really he already
does the coaching stuff and he thought
that I would be a good fit for that and
he saw an opportunity for us to work
together as a team and he and he
proposed like hey we should start this
this program this coaching program so we
did and he used a lot of what he learned
from my story and building the
curriculum making a lot of things
teachable about menu and movement
mindset and how how to couch a lot of
the things the way that I sort of
captured in my brain and and and so we
did that for a few years and one of his
podcast guests just so happened to be
this tech person who was building a an
online platform and it was gonna be an
app and all and she was kind of it she's
like she saw what we did with our with
our coaching stuff she's like I think we
should have an opportunity so we kind of
right we flirted with that for a while
and wind up mashing together and now I'm
a founder of this tech company right
right yeah we're gonna have a native app
in in about three or four weeks we just
had a meeting so we just had our first
like corporate meeting in San Diego that
was really cool all face to face and I
feel all like I'm part of something it's
it's exciting it's scary cuz I have no
idea what I'm doing and I know what I'm
doing when I'm talking to people when
I'm relating what what Howard and I've
been working on and honing but when it
comes to like this the the being part of
a start-up or a tech startup especially
I'm kind of
like it's kind of overwhelming at times
but it's really fun and something very
rewarding the surrender to I have to say
that's cool
so so it's called well stars but it'll
be like an app that'll have online
coaching or yeah it's it will have
Howard's built out this 12-week program
and then we do like these weekly
coaching calls where it's like a group
coach on video right group coaching
calls on video once a week and we have a
we have a plant-based diet ition and we
just try to help everybody orient into
that growth mindset we're not gonna tell
you what to do right now we help you
identify where you are and we're trying
to help you nudge into that direction of
better that we've identified because you
have type 2 diabetes or you're
overweight or we've we've quantified
we've made specific goals here and so
that's that's all we do and through a
12-week program we do that I'll do like
daily like two-minute videos where we
text the people and I get a challenge
their songs yeah get a bunch of those
other people look like people love them
so we just keep doing some funny and um
but it seems to really help we have some
amazing success stories in there and I'm
really made some real deep personal
friendships and relationships through
this whole thing with some of the people
that have been through the program we
live in do you have a date for libraries
or no in the the the CTO said three or
four weeks Wow
in the meeting so that's exciting that's
the that's the plan
super and that would be really cool and
what was really cool was as we're at
plan trician and we have the booth out
and we sort of explain what we're doing
and now we have dr. sera stanczyk as our
as our of our chief medical officer
she's because she was a fly on the wall
in our program she was like oh my god
this is what we need this is what
physicians need and so she was
mouthpiece in us and a plane trician all
weekend it was just really surreal for
me to be there and have like Michael
Greger standing there talking about well
start with us going I really
that's pretty cool you know that's
amazing to me yeah that is that's
amazing to me
you know come a long way my friend right
but it's so and I got it who knows where
it's going and it's so fun like every
day is a mystery like I'm in and I'm
sitting I'm sitting at your house right
now I wouldn't I mean this is crazy to
me I was just I was welling up with
tears just driving up as the as the he
got closer and closer is like four miles
- miles I was like oh I just like touch
that you drove all the way from San
Diego - come on yeah we only got a few
minutes left here and I can't let you go
without spending a little bit of time
trying to get practical ons on some
tools and some takeaways for some people
who are listening who you know maybe are
stuck maybe are flirting with the idea
of trying to change their relationship
with food or fitness or trying to get
into running you know what are what are
the common things that people come to
you with and what are some of the ways
forward like how do people just you know
make that start and then make it stick
well we I'm gonna say something that my
grandfather always told me on a job site
right because I was always the boss's
grandson on the site and he didn't want
me standing around getting caught like
looking lazy or not doing something and
so he told me he gave me directions when
I was like when I was very young that he
said I want you doing something even if
it's wrong so so that's the first step
we got to do something you analyze you
think you think plant basis analysis
paralysis at now exactly so what we want
to do is we want to do something I don't
care which step that is I don't care
what it is we want to do something let's
get a result and let's let's let our
results dictate the sufficiency of what
it is we're doing today and must be
objective and pragmatic about it because
dammit we're trying to get somewhere
let's do this on purposes do it with
purpose and let's understand it we have
a community of people around us that are
kind of dependent on us it's hard to be
motivated yourself when you see every
around you failing so play your role be
a part do it for yourself do it for your
community do it for the family around
you and um and you know let's take the
first step whatever that is do it man
yeah one of the things that that you
talk about on the regular is this idea
of majoring in the minors yeah yeah
that's a yeah yeah which I love and I
think it's so true so like explain that
yeah that's actually my buddy
my buddy Ryan and and he works at the
Wellness Center in Thibodeau and he
posted an Instagram that he that's what
he called it majoring in the minors were
you worried about all that he's tiny my
new detail is about arsenic in rice and
glyphosate in here
oats but she ate chicken last night you
ate you know you ate pizza last night
so let's take the low-hanging fruit
right now let's identify that and let's
go after the low-hanging fruit let's not
worry about the six fist-sized servings
of kale a day right now let's stop
eating pizza right now and let's move a
start it's not necessarily about the
food it's about the purposeful habit
change it's about being conscious of
what you're doing and doing something on
purpose that's different because we want
different outcomes and we understand we
had the power to manifest those mm-hmm
and and so it's a growth mindset it's
not plant based it's not it's a it's
that's what it's about it's about
understanding how to get pragmatic and
how to adopt a growth mindset and love
yourself enough to perpetually creep
forward and when we can do that
I think everyone's gonna wind up plant
bass everyone's gonna find it for a
runner if you really honestly do that
and let gravity have its Pettit's way
the growth mindset thing is key because
I think what happens with a lot of
people is they'll be a window of
opportunity or some moment where they're
blessed with the willingness to make
that change and they're pretty good for
a couple weeks but then something will
happen they got to go out of town or you
know I don't know you know they just
they have a weak moment and they
faceplant in the Papa John's or whatever
yeah and then they're like well I
couldn't
it and done you know and then they're
just back to whatever they were doing
and it's so hard to recreate that
momentum but if you really are in a
place where you're adopting this growth
mindset it's much easier to just get
back on track okay but I'm not gonna
like shame myself right out of the game
I'm just gonna look forward what's the
next best thing that I can do and get
back on track and start to recreate that
momentum or not allow that momentum to
lose too much of its acceleration that's
exactly right
you know is it's just the old adage of
how you eat elephant one bite at a time
we have to you have to just keep taking
bites it's can and I get you know from
you it's it's consistency over intensity
that's what's most important of course
you know yeah so you're at you're a
plant Rishon and you got a booth and you
got to start out your startup founder
and you know you're just a guy from the
bio who did a podcast one day and then
said yes when you could go meet you know
the three old ladies down the street and
teach them how to cook something a
little bit healthier yeah
so hot you know that happens with taking
those tiny bites out of the elephant
every single day
that's exactly right you know the
elephant may not okay think of this
whole behavior change think of your life
think of this whole thing as growing
something literally because if you think
of it Disney can make a very convincing
oak tree but it's not an oak tree right
if you what it takes to really make an
oak tree is years and years of nurturing
in slow growth consolidation Feldman I
know like they want that what's the Hat
that's that's an issue let's talk about
that because that's got to go away you
know we don't want pay debts that's
that's a that's uh that's in the way
that's in a way of what we're trying to
do so we gotta we gotta back off of that
we need to talk about we need to talk
about planting a seed and then
fertilizing that seed and then growing
it nurse
into a tree that ultimately bears fruit
that's what that's what we need to do
and if we can build community around
that then we have this growth medium for
those roots to really set in you know
and that's how we grow not only
individual behavior change but a
movement and how we move in a direction
to not only you know save this country
but really save humankind man because
it's on a terrible trajectory and it's
this sad because it's just because of
the [ __ ] we eat
it's crazy times so much of it is hey
come on it's not that complicated I love
you brother
I could go on for another two hours but
please come back when you're gonna have
this freakin book done it's gonna be
it's gonna be soon actually yeah we're
just gonna give away we have this we
have I have a memoir of mine it's that's
later down the road but we've basically
taken everything that comprises our big
our our um well well start program and
put it into a book free Kindle inversion
so to give it a lessee right and I'll go
hand-in-hand with that correct that's
all you just have it and then you don't
need us but if you want us we're there
yeah we'll give you all the stuff we're
gonna give you just whatever that's good
man yeah and 50k in February 50k in
February and just I'll be taking I'll be
taking I'll probably pace a few friends
along the way for half's and fools as I
get ready but I'd like to do if I think
I want to race a 50k before I try to
race another marathon so I really love
the ultras yeah they're spiritual
odyssey's man you know they look real
good I Love You Man love you too Vegas
so much it's been an honor and a
privilege to observe your trajectory and
I'm so proud of you man it's beautiful
what you've created and like I said at
the outset I really do think it's just
the beginning and I think you're you're
just on your way to making a profile
impact on culture and people and and
bless you man man's you thank you so
much for being there for me and just
being a friend that you are you people
don't know how much of a mentor you
already with texting and you're
constantly there for word for advice and
any questions you give you just an
amazing human being enough thank you
very much for everything that you've
done for me it really means a lot
my pleasure man josh is easy to find on
the Internet at joshula Johnny I mean
instagrams your main job yeah yeah and
Facebook too right yeah you're a small
Twitter but like your Facebook and if
you can find if you can find a missing
chins and and compose some kind of
eloquent letter yeah leave GoFundMe is
out and maybe he'll let you in yeah
and that's it man is there anything
about well start on the internet if
people want to read about that no other
know what I'm putting this podcast up
maybe it'll coincide with the launch so
let me know when that is
yeah sure I don't know yeah I don't know
exactly when the when the native app
launches we're live right now on our on
our website it behaves like an app on
the phone when I would done at well
story Hill it's like mobile optimized
right what's the website for them well
start we'll start health.com we'll start
like you're not sure about know it
sergeant
all right now until we until we meet
again you take us out peace plants
[Music]
you